les collèges et les lycées du
département vont accueillir plus de 140
mille jeunes pour cette rentrée des
nouveautés notamment dans les lycées
présentée par valérie pécresse la
président de la région ile de france
mardi 31 août alors du côté du numérique
d'ici les vacances de la toussaint 100 %
des lycées seront couverts par le wifi
ces établissements seront aussi pour
cette rentrée 100% numérique avec des
outils pédagogiques nouveau des des
manuels des manuels scolaires des
applications qui permettront de faire de
faire des sciences de faire des lettres
un laboratoire de langues embarqué qui
ose qui permet maintenant d'apprendre le
français l'anglais l'espagnol le
portugais l'allemand et le mandarin donc
énormément d'outils pédagogiques et un
environnement numérique de travail mon
lycée point net qui peut supporter un
million cinq cent mille connexions par
jour autres enjeux identifiés par la
région le pouvoir d'achat des familles
le prix minimal de la cantine calculé en
fonction du quotient familial est fixé à
50 centimes d'euros et 100 % des lycées
seront équipés en distributeurs gratuit
de protections périodiques alors autres
annonces faites le point sur les travaux
en mars 2010 est un plan de 5 milliards
d'euros est mis en place pour 2017 2020
un plan amplifiée en 2021 pour notamment
créer de nouvelles places comme le lycée
camille claudel à mantes la ville pour
300 places supplémentaires 800 places
seront à créer à conflans poissy de
sorte à aller plus vite et plus efficace
des plans ciblé c'est pour les cdi pour
les sanitaires pour les équipements
sportifs de sorte à pouvoir aller plus
vite et plus fort nous avons en 2015
prix et des lycées dans un état souvent
pitoyable et ce grand plan de
modernisation permet de rattraper le
retard de sorte à accueillir l'ensemble
des quelques 500 mille lycéens dans des
conditions dignes
cette année scolaire sera marquée par
une nouvelle campagne d'appels auprès
des élèves identifiés comme décrocheurs
en 2020 2021 des solutions ont été mises
en place pour 51% d'entre eux des
assises réuniront les différents acteurs
à l'automne 2021 et cette rentrée est à
nouveau une rentrée sous le co vie un
kit sanitaire sera remis à chaque élève
la région propose de mettre en place
aussi des navettes pour se rendre dans
des centres de vaccination des capteurs
de co2 sont installés tout comme des
purificateurs d'air à la demande des
établissements